for new rules everybody new bureau now
that the University of North Georgia has
put out this why follow when you can
lead course guide that chose white men
winning out over a woman and a black man
they have to change their name to
cracker state cracker state home of the
flying bullets where our Black Studies
program is our basketball team
new rule before Amy's kitchen recalls
all their gluten-free tofu breakfast
wraps figures there may be Listeria in
the spinach they have to tell us what
Listeria tastes like because if it
tastes good at all I say leave it in
there all the 33 year old Mexican woman
who was arrested in a movie theater
masturbating to Fifty Shades of Grey ha
ha ha
has to stop kicking my seat
it's bad enough sitting through all
these trailers without you coming soon
please I'm watching a terrible movie
from an illiterate book while people
around me talking text on their phones
don't make it disgusting new rule now
that we're normalizing relations with
Cuba we have to buy them a new boat
although they do get props for inventing
the first hybrid Chevy new role since
he's never going to be President Ted
Cruz has to enjoy this moment where he
can act like he is how do I know you're
not going to be President Ted because
even your daughter is looking up and you
like really
and finally new rule don't throw the
synthetic baby out with the bathwater
last week you may have seen that the
iconic designers Dolce and Gabanna
caused a ruckus when they said that even
though they're proudly gay when it comes
to how are you making a Bambino
they're old-school Italians who don't
approve of what they called synthetic
children because you know synthetics
they just don't breathe like cotton well
naturally a backlash ensued and now
people are refusing to wear this shirt
and you know what so am i but nothing
but not because I'm protesting something
because I'm not Persian
you